[Music]
please welcome the very funny kurt
brownler
[Applause]
thank you thank you uh guys i haven't
been on instagram today does anybody
know if the sunset
or if anybody ate any food
i just like to keep in touch
uh i went into a store just down the
street recently when i walked in the
sales lady just went it's good to see
you
i was like i don't know how to deal with
this information at all
so i just did the only thing i thought
was appropriate and i just said it's
been too long and i kissed her on the
mouse
i uh i recently just moved to la and so
i've been driving a lot listening to la
radio and i did not know that 90 of la
radio is just sublime
i had no idea
but i like it i found that i have a
favorite sublime song it's the song
where the sublime guy goes uh i can play
a guitar like a mother effing riot and
then just slowly plink plonks on an
acoustic guitar
just plink plonk please punk plink plunk
i was like that is a
riot if your definition of a ride is
just one lone seagull trying to get a
sandwich out from inside a baby grand
piano
scared and confused
i uh i like to do stupid things to
strangers because i think it helps make
the world a better place so
guys here's three fun things you can do
today to make the world a better place
one next time you fart just yell
nothing but net
it's confusing
and fun to say
two
next time you go into a cafe to read a
book right before you open your book
just look up and yell y'all ready for
this
and then quietly open your book and
start reading
number three you won't see the effects
of this but you'll know you did an
awesome thing go to facebook find a
stranger go like a year back in their
photos and just like one photo
keep them guessing for hours
who is this
and why do they like this picture of me
eating pizza
i like to do weird things like that
maybe because of the way i was raised i
i don't mean to disturb you but i now
have to tell you three true facts about
myself kurt brownlower fact number one
i breastfed until i was five years old
five
deal with that
look at me and know that's true five
that's some game of thrones [ __ ] y'all
five
i have a specific memory of
breastfeeding and watching tv and asking
my mom to change a channel cause i was
bored
five
i didn't know it was weird until i
started telling people
but also i'm six foot four and i never
get sick
fact number two
my best friend from ages five to ten had
tourette's and i had no idea
he moved away at age ten and after he
left my mom was like you know mike had
tourette's i was like what's that she's
like watch this video i was like oh
somebody should have told me
because i've just been mimicking him
back to himself all the time
i thought it was our fun way of chatting
with each other
i'd just be like yeah
okay and then agree with him again and
hit him
third fact
i started smoking
when i was 10 years old
what up jersey
10.
five years
after i stopped breastfeeding
i started smoking
and the entire time in between i was
pretending like i had tourette's
that's how you make this soup thank you
so much ladies and gentlemen
that's fantastic thank you so much that
was great awesome thank
you ladies and gentlemen